how do I secure my data and apps in
cloud cloud security it's all about
responsibility at Google Cloud we've got
your back with shared fate it's like
having a security BFF who's always there
to catch you when you fall we take
infrastructure security so seriously
it's like we've built a fortress out of
custom hardware and stripped down Linux
we even have purpose-built chips for
data security we have your data
encrypted at rest and in motion for
network security we handle the traffic
and Communications with other services
on public internet securely and you
manage additional defenses but don't
worry Google cloud has got your back
with virtual private Cloud firewall
rules and VPC service controls for
application security you're on your own
but don't panic we have got tools such
as Cloud armor API management and load
balancer and with recapture Enterprise
you can finally tell those pesky Bots to
buzz off